arguably the most globally recognized
mythical creature from Australia is the
Bunya an important staple in aboriginal
folklore this amphibious being poses a
threat to all who travel near inland
waters lurking in lagoons deep waterhole
swamps and rivers this predatory
creature presents a clear danger to
humans and animals alike threatening to
drown or eat them at a moment's notice
originating in the stories and beliefs
of the southeastern indigenous peoples
of Australia accounts of the Bunya are
widely varied but a few things are for
certain it's big scary and won't
hesitate to kill you
i'm dr. emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
the word bunyan most likely came from an
Aboriginal word for an amphibious spirit
being australian indigenous peoples
believe the beans are separate from the
ancestors and the Aboriginal people
themselves and were believed to exist
alongside humans the bunyip goes by
several other names depending on who is
telling the story the tricky thing about
bunyips is that there are so many
different accounts as to what the
creature actually looks like while many
of these sightings describe a
four-legged creature resembling a seal
others tell of a chimera type being
resembling different animals like emus
horses kangaroos and alligators some
stories claim the Bunya has Shaggy and
long hair while others say it has
feathers or scales
booming noises and loud roars indicate
their presence and they are even capable
of causing illness some indigenous
accounts give the bunny up the powers of
sorcery capable of luring their victims
to them which makes them even more
dangerous the huge number of variations
of the bunyips reported appearance seem
confusing at first glance but you could
argue that the variation of the creature
is what has kept it alive in Australia
for so long there's no one cohesive
story because there is no one group of
indigenous Aboriginal peoples before
Europeans colonized Australia there was
an estimated 250 different languages
spoken there then at different cultures
and geographic locations and the
variations between Bunya accounts begin
to make more sense regardless of the
form this water spirit takes or the
details of the story the Bunya always
functions as a warning of the danger of
inland water it serves as a lesson to
children and adults alike to respect the
unpredictability of water and the
dangers it presents one Aboriginal story
tells of a four-legged milk-white bunion
with a big bull head and large eyes that
browse the land looking for wrongdoers
to attack in another story the Bunya
clerks in the water with its glowing red
eyes attacking a woman who goes to fetch
water at night tearing off her arm the
next morning when the creature is hunted
all that can be found is a blood-covered
black and red feather in another
Aboriginal story a boy is taken by a
bunion while playing by the river at
night referred to as the old fellow the
bunion takes the boy to its cave an
adult goes to save the boy rubbing his
body with dead body fat before diving
into the river and finding the cave
there he waves feathers and sings
putting the bunny up to sleep and
bringing the boy back to safety
although the Bunya poses a severe threat
harming them was often taboo
another tale tells of a steamer that
suddenly comes to a halt in the river
the captain goes to shoot the bun yup
that is keeping the barge in place the
others aboard warn him don't do that if
you do that you will die don't do that
you'll die a bad death
but he doesn't heed their warning and
kills the creature the captain later
gets very sick his whole body covered in
oozing blisters and in two weeks he is
dead the stories of the Bunya were told
by the indigenous peoples with such
conviction and vividness that the first
european explorers and colonizers to
hear of this creature initially believed
that it must be some prehistoric animal
that remained unidentified by european
science and believed that they would
eventually find a specimen to study it's
worth keeping in mind that real
Australian fauna was totally foreign and
flat-out weird to European travelers
things like black swans wombats platypus
and echidnas were seen by Europeans for
the first time in the 19th century add
to that the discovery of large megafauna
fossils and the idea of the bunyip
seemed less far-fetched at the time take
the Diprotodon an extinct giant
marsupial with claws whose appearance
resembles some of the large hairy
descriptions of bunyips then there's
this slightly smaller megafauna species
that indigenous australians lived
alongside for at least 17,000 years
newspapers in the 19th century reported
bunny up sightings and proposed
explanations theories included
crocodiles misplaced sea mammals like
seals fossil bones the duck-billed
platypus swamp gas and a sounds from
swamp birds like the Australasian
bittern bird who has commonly called the
Bunyip bird for its nocturnal nature and
booming call in 1846 a book about
Australia published in London included
an excerpt from an 1845 Australian
newspaper article about the discovery of
a supposed Bunyip bone making the legend
international in 1847 in what is now New
South Wales a cycloptic head was
presented for examination as possible
evidence of the creature advertised as a
bunion skull it was put on display for
public viewing at the Australian Museum
in Sydney
but the specimen was eventually
identified by naturalist WS McClay to
likely be the malformed skull of a full
altered with taxidermy to appear even
more unusual while speculations of the
bunyip circulated geographer George
Windsor Earle proposed that the bunyip
was really a dugong a manatee like water
mammal some folklore says that before
the rivers were dammed in southeastern
Australia one of the bunyips most
prominent areas all kinds of oceanic
creatures from sharks to small whales
would occasionally travel inland
Australia does have the world's largest
population of dugongs it is possible
that high sea tides during the summer
and low river levels could have led to
an animal usually only seen at sea
making its way into more interior areas
of the country while older beliefs like
the Dreaming ancestors and ghosts and
spirits endured Aboriginal folklore was
influenced by European cultures which
can help explain why from the mid 19th
century on the Bunyip was described more
as a humanoid spirit and in one instance
a half-man half-fish
with a matted crop of reeds for hair to
me it matters less what creature or
thing actually inspired the bunyips
physical appearance then the fact that
it persisted for so long an Aboriginal
culture Bunyip stories force a
recognition of the varied cultural and
spiritual beliefs of the indigenous
peoples of Australia before
anglo-european intervention these tales
solidify indigenous identities and
connections to the landscape in a long
tradition that continues today
[Music]
you